okay who's the bad guy here is the guy
behind the counter
or is the person who's filming this or
is it tariq nasheed who posted this
online
you can either be the person who's
forgiving about people having bad days
or you can be the person
who's a jackass now when we moved our
company from california to tennessee i
can tell you it's like everybody sort of
took a
deep breath a sigh of relief same thing
when i moved my family from california
to florida and one of the reasons is
because we had self-selected
into an area where more people were not
going to be
savagely looking for our destruction
well online that's what people do
and this has become a national issue and
so people are looking for places where
they don't feel like they're going to be
destroyed every day so this is the best
example of something like this i've ever
seen it really is amazing so tariq
nasheed
who is just a terrible person the sort
of pseudo journalist
i've been a number of twitter fights
with him because he's just not a good
human being
so he tweeted out a video it now has
three million views
and here's how he described it a white
holiday inn express worker
has a nervous breakdown after he got
scolded by a black customer because of a
mistake in the reservation system
so if you just read that what you would
imagine is here is a white employee
who's having a nervous breakdown because
he's a racist right
we got we gotta we gotta torment we
gotta torment this guy because probably
he's a racist
okay now this video is super hard to
watch i'll describe it for for people
who are listening
because it really is very difficult to
watch this is a person pretty obviously
the person behind the counter
who has pre-existing mental issues right
this is perfectly obvious just from
watching the video you can tell this is
true
right and it turns out that now there is
a it turns out
that now there is uh the guy has has
apparently come out on reddit and
explained who he is he said that he has
borderline personality disorder and
schizo and and some some schizoid
tendencies apparently according
to his reddit he says he has
schizoaffective disorders as well
okay so there are a lot of people who
are speculating that he might have some
sort of
some borderline autism or something like
that in any case whatever the mental
condition is very obvious this guy has a
mental condition and
according to this guy apparently the
person who is filming him
not only was harassing him but called
him the f word for gay people
and turns out the guy's gay so just a
wonderful example
of an anti-racist warrior really making
life better for everybody by targeting
this employee now let me just ask you
if you've ever dealt with a person at a
hotel who hasn't been wildly
wildly competent right a person who's
trying to deal with a problem having
trouble dealing with the problem
if you're the person who harasses that
person and puts it on tape you're the
jackass
it's that simple and if you are the if
you are the person
who is at the airport harassing the
stewardesses you're the bad person if
you're the person
who is at the hotel harassing the guy
behind the desk because the computer's
screwing up
you're the bad person but in our new
reality tariq nasheed makes you a hero
if you are black and the person behind
the counter is white because that person
must be a racist
for starting it up tight if you treat
them badly this is one of the saddest
videos i've ever seen
it went completely viral and if tariq
nasheed out his way this guy's life
would be destroyed right now
here is the video why did you get mad
and hit the computer
i'm sure you're on camera right yeah i'm
gonna shoot you on camera
okay the guy is actually punching his
own face and now he's ramming his head
into the computer screen so there's a
type of
people that here working here and
and he's breaking down
[Music]
he says i've got to go
he says you're ruining my whole life
yeah and then he goes in the other room
and you can hear him crying and yelling
okay who's the bad guy here
is the guy behind the counter or is the
person who's filming this or is it tariq
nasheed who posted this online
it's not the guy behind the counter
everybody has bad days
hey forget about whether you're mentally
ill or not mentally ill every single
human being
you know has bad days you can either be
the person who's forgiving about people
having bad days or you can be the person
who's a jackass you can be the person
who seeks to destroy somebody's life
even the person who trolls twitter for
people who have made inappropriate
comments or a joke you didn't like
and then you can try and wreck them you
can find the person
who was having a crappy day and made a
bad comment at a supermarket and you can
tape them you can put them on tape you
can wreck their life
see social trust relies on us being able
to be at least somewhat forgiving with
one another and understand that human
beings are sinful
and that human beings are vulnerable and
then human beings say bad things to one
another all the time
and if you're a good person you let a
lot of that stuff go because you have
sympathy for other human beings
i i was at a an event in the not too
distant past and i was talking to this
one guy and he was obviously very drunk
uh and he and he came up and he made
what i thought was
kind of an anti-jewish reference and he
was very very drunk
and at that point i thought to myself
okay well i can turn this into a
confrontation
or i could take out my camera and i i
here's the truth i didn't even go
through this calculation i just figured
the guy's drunk he's having a bad day
and you know what he was drunk and he
was probably having a bad day
i didn't ruin his life it wouldn't have
been appropriate for me to ruin his life
but we live in a culture that prizes you
you are a hero if you ruin somebody's
life we are we live in a culture where
if you are a
student in high school and you post a
video of yourself
celebrating getting your provisional
driver's license and you quote a rap
lyric using the n-word
a member of your class will take that
video and then it will hold it over your
head for several years and then destroy
your dreams by sending it to the
university where you have just been
admitted
and getting you thrown off the
cheerleading team and then getting it
thrown out of the university
and then you'll get a feature piece in
the new york times about how brave and
wonderful you were
so how do you think people react to that
sort of thing how do you think people
react
they leave they say i don't want to live
in an area where people act like this
i don't want to be around people who act
like this
not with regard to race or ethnicity or
any other immutable characteristic i
don't want to live around people who are
this unforgiving
and this nasty people who are not going
to treat me like a fully rounded nuanced
human being who's never allowed to have
a bad day
now one of the things that uh i was
recently watching this michael jordan
documentary and there's this fascinating
part of the documentary is the last
dance on netflix
uh and uh there's a fascinating part of
the documentary where michael jordan
is in his hotel room and the cameraman's
in there with him they say you know
michael you basically own the city why
are you sitting around the hotel room he
says you understand every time i leave
this hotel room there are cameras on me
and i have to be on
now as somebody who's fairly well known
i have a little bit of the same thing
right when i'm
outdoors when i'm at parties i have to
be on right i have to know that somebody
is probably filming me at all times it's
very tiring
okay but i chose my career i chose what
i do for a living
the problem is this is now applied to
every single human every single human
feels like they always have to be on
that is exhausting it's very tiring it
is because it means that you have to be
watching what you say all the time
you're afraid you're gonna make a joke
you're afraid you're gonna make a
reference somebody's gonna grab it
somebody's gonna post it and then your
life is ruined and your family's life is
ruined your kid's life is ruined
or alternatively you could live in a
community that has a baseline level of
trust and that baseline level of trust
is
a little bit of forgiveness a little bit
of flexibility in what people say and
what people do
and understanding that somebody can be
having a bad day and it doesn't make
them a bad person
that somebody can say something
inappropriate and it could be accidental
or it could be
something slipping or it could be a just
a bad tendency that the person has but
they happen to be out of control that
day
and that the best response to that is
not to publicly shame that person and
ruin their life but maybe to go to them
privately
and say you know that was really hurtful
and you shouldn't have said that
the lack of forgiveness in our society
is leading people to find more forgiving
communities
now i have some faith that there will be
a re-uptick in religious affiliation
specifically because religious
affiliation does do this
it creates a feeling of unity inside
communities
where you are in the hebrew phrase
likely to engage in down the half's
close
right which means to see people for
their merit as opposed to see people for
their demerits but we're a society that
now
has this this lavar burton-esque
accountability culture well i have a
i have a question who are you to hold
anybody else accountable have you never
said anything
that you regret have you never tweeted
anything that regret have you ever had a
bad day
who do you want to be in that video this
is the question for you and for all of
america who do you want to be in that
video
do you want to would you rather be the
guy behind the counter or would you
rather be the guy who's in front of the
counter filming him
and mocking him or would you rather be
the person who doesn't have to deal with
any of that because they live in a
community where people treat each other
decently
the left which says that everybody has
to be treated nicely everybody's
identity
has to be has to be protected and
sheltered and their self-identification
has to be prized and cheered by society
that same left will destroy you if they
cross you
they will destroy you if you disagree
with them
and so people are sorting a great sort
is happening and ideological sorting is
happening in this country it's being
exacerbated
by national media and it's going to
happen in every area of american life
it's going to happen in corporate
america too
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like
and subscribe to help keep our videos on
the front line of the fight and top of
your feet